hey everyone welcome back to the
corridor cast and today's episode is
proudly sponsored by audible more on
that in a bit but today's guest is
Andrew price known on YouTube as the
blender guru he's basically the world's
foremost expert on educating people on
how to use a 3d program called blender
fantastic guy really smart Australian we
got him here in the podcast to talk
about all kinds of things like photo
realism and making tutorials and running
a business he also runs a company called
polygon which provides all kinds of
textures for 3d artists yeah let's get
to it
you know I would see your your-your-your
thumbnails on youtube and suggested
stuff and like you know that what is the
the photorealism one your video essay on
like photo realism and talk about all
that and you know a lot of people are
like oh I don't have blender so why do I
need to watch a blender tutorial if I'm
not using blender yeah like you guys
gotta watch these videos man you use a
3d program called blender yes I agree to
use program for pretty much everything
3d it does actually a lot of stuff years
ago it didn't do as much stuff but these
days it's doing a lot Clint and I on the
other hand we primarily use cinema 4d
mm-hmm which is a very different 3d
package but it at the end of the day it
does the same thing different user
interface yeah so we might not be able
to get much out of a direct tutorial
that you make but all the concepts are
there so it's still like an interesting
thing to watch especially cuz a lot of
your tutorials kind of are based around
like the theory and and why you do
certain things as opposed but ins to get
to the end yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah my I
yet my initial treat because I've been
doing it for like 10 years now making
YouTube tutorials man and it yeah at the
start it was all like you got to push
the buttons in the right order this kind
of thing and then I realized like you
know when I'm watching a tutorial myself
if I only learn how to push the buttons
in the correct order then I'm only gonna
be able to make that thing that that
person made yeah and so then it was like
okay well well then how could you you
know without explaining every single
thing explain the concepts of what
you're doing and so lately the the most
recent
style of tutorial I've done his like I'm
gonna show you how to make this finished
scene but I'm not gonna do it over two
hours like I would usually I'm gonna
compress it to 10 minutes or 20 minutes
and just show you the actual like
important things or a technique that I
picked up all like don't use this type
of light when you're lighting through
the interior because it's just gonna
make extra render times well this is a
better style than this and then you sort
of speed up the rest of it and I I gave
it a as an experiment and it worked it
worked really well so yeah I I really
like the format it's very very very
satisfying to watch so the you know the
button by button a couple couple things
so first off like I think that your
method of doing it currently where it's
like the 20 minute video and you're kind
of commentating on your style and what
you did and like you're hitting the key
moments that you think need to be talked
about the important stuff mm-hmm that's
cool because it leaves the audience when
I'm watching tutorial you're like type
in 56 for the opacity and you know 32
for the scale it's like oh I gotta get
it just right it's not gonna look right
mm-hmm but the way you do it it almost
gives it what totally gives the audience
the ability to be more creatively free
right and it lets it lets the audience
and gives the audience a chance to do
their own thing and experiment in their
own way you know yeah I think that's a
really cool teaching method in a
teaching style too so yeah I mean that
but at the same time when you're first
starting out you have no idea what
you're doing
so like to a certain degree when you
literally have never used the program
before you have to have your hand held
through it because you don't even know
what a button is at that point you know
I know I've made a lot of tutorials too
so it's like this is really interesting
talking with another fellow tutorial
maker because I feel like we've had
different processes over the years
because I know the way I like to make
tutorials as um I will practice an
effect even if I'd already know how to
do it I will make that same effect like
three times mm-hmm in a row like just
over and over and over again from
scratch so that by the time I'm actually
sitting down to record I know the exact
next step to do and even still I'll take
like breaks halfway through a tutorial
or I'll just be talking and then I'll
just stop talking and stare my screen
like 30 straight seconds then you click
on the pen tool yeah cuz I always I go
back through and I edit out all the
breaks I try to make it as seamless as
possible
not necessarily seamless I don't care
too much about the seams as much as just
trying to get the information to be the
most efficient it can be yeah right is
that's what it comes down to I don't
waste certain time but I also don't want
them to be lost
yes and so it also depends on the kind
of effect I'm doing kind of a more
easier beginner style effect I'll be a
little bit more detailed with what to do
if it's a little bit more of an advanced
effect I won't even bother teaching them
like ok this is how you make a mask I'll
spell okay hit F on the keyboard to
feather it out yeah that's right well
that that's that's an important point
it's like you you can't explain
everything because you would get you
would irritate everybody like if you
were talking to them like they were a
baby the entire time and I used the left
click on your thing to select and drag
over to like you just drive everybody up
the wall it's one of the things I find
kind of amusing about andrew kramer's
tutorials from videocopilot some
consider him to be like the king of like
um yeah yeah he makes great tutorials
but I always find it funny he'll be
doing like like his most recent tutorial
which was about like these letters
getting chopped in half by like
asteroids flying through him is a pretty
advanced procedural effect inside of
After Effects and he's going through all
this these advanced maneuvers and he
still is like alright and I'm gonna go
up to edit copy and then click on this
other layer go up to edit paste as
opposed to just be like this point you
probably know how to hit ctrl-c and
ctrl-v like right right yeah yeah it's
yeah it's it's hard it's definitely hard
to get it right and you never will
because somebody will be more advanced
and somebody will be more beginner I've
had people on the same video say you'd
going too fast and you're going too slow
right the same video I mean it's just
they're at different speeds to other
people do you record your audio while
you're actually doing the recording of
the screen recording yeah it it's not
like it's not like it's after the fact I
do both okay it depends on what I'm
doing so like if it's a theory video
like the like photorealism or something
yeah where it's like sort of more
fleshed out production like I've got so
I'll just do the audio
um or now I've got the webcam so I just
do the video thing and then later on on
to the visuals to it trouble with that
is if you go to professional I've
noticed you kind of lose I don't know
what the word is you lose a kind of
casualness that some people actually
like when you record a casual it is like
the more professional you get with your
production many YouTube video it's like
the less relatable it is and the less
and that's not the case for all like
videos or channels but it tends to be
like it's the biggest example is
comparing uh
Hollywood stars coming to YouTube like
Will Smith versus Jack Black Will Smith
has like a huge amount of money or go to
each of his videos very obviously it's
shown on camera right whereas Jack Black
is like obviously I'm recording this on
a cellphone and my son's editing it yeah
it's like yeah yeah I can't get any more
classic og YouTube than Jack Black right
now that's true
where's nice really well like
integrating in the YouTube culture yeah
like just all the same jokes the dummy
like it's like wow he's been watching
YouTube for a while I think yeah but I
mean that was a bit of a derailment from
what you're saying is like right you
don't want to add too much production
value to your thing cuz maybe that'll
make it a little bit I don't know like
less yeah you really well you lose like
because you have to basically if you've
got prepared words you're gonna say you
know like I've written out scripts right
and write out the script and I say it
word for word and I listen back to it I
go [ __ ] it sucks I sound like I'm
selling for brizel so like I'm like
ladies and gentle like mmm horrible
nobody wants to listen to that I feel
like a lot of people can tell the
difference between listening to prepared
statements and just off the cuff
exactly yeah yeah and so this is the
thing I've learned you essentially have
to become an actor you have to pretend
as though I'm reading this for the first
time okay and I'm gonna go about this
casually and I have to ensure like when
I'm doing the videos and I come to this
part that I know and I've spoken about
before cuz I've done three or five takes
on it but you have to actor though I
just had this funny idea or this like
it's not being funny it's the opposite
of fun it's like you
if you were to read it off the cuff this
is how I would sound but if I just read
off the cuff this video is gonna be two
hours long because it's gonna take two
hours to get to that point yeah
so it's rehearsed but it's sounding like
it's off the guy it's very hard to do
but I know exactly what I mean I'm
making videos where I'm having like
memorize a lot of lines to deliver to
camera mm-hmm yeah and it's like what I
actually write down and then I say it
out loud I was like I don't sound like
that why did I write that way yeah I end
up having to just kind of like come up
with the main things I want to say and
then just improvise the actual that's
what I'm learning as well if you write
it would for what you will actually
sound too static yeah whereas if you
just give sort of the main bullet points
and the kind of the flow it can you can
riff on it a bit yeah before we go any
further I want to just listen to a
message from our sponsor
yeah no it's our first sponsor it is one
of my favorite sponsors audible I know
right okay check it out all right the
reason why I really like audible
sponsorships is cuz it basically just
gives me an excuse to talk about a book
I really liked so today's sponsor is
audible in the book I'm gonna be talking
about is called fear the sky it's a
sci-fi book takes place on earth
basically getting invaded by aliens so
you can actually get your first
audiobook free when you sign up for a 30
day trial at audible.com slash coridor
cast or you can even text message court
or cast 2 500 500 those are both good
ways to get into this program so fear
the sky what kind of book is this it's a
sci-fi book basically aliens like
there's a million aliens on a spaceship
heading towards Earth and they don't
they don't care about humans they just
want our planet and you know Humanity is
not really any the wiser right now
except that they've sent eight special
force androids ahead of time imprinted
with very smart people so it's like you
got actual aliens running around in
Android bodies here on the earth and
their whole purpose is to basically
deactivate the whole nuclear program on
on earth because the aliens they want to
live here they don't want it to be all
radioactive and so that's the thing
there's a scientist on earth who has
discovered this whole plan and so now
they're trying to they're trying to form
a resistance against them and they have
to do it very stealthily because there's
these satellites in orbit who have
lasers that can like kill people
instantly from space and so it's it's
this really cool story of trying to fly
back against an overwhelmingly powerful
force without any of that powerful force
even noticing that the resisting it's a
really fun thriller really high paced
high-octane science fiction ya know it's
a great book I've read it twice or
rather I should say I've listened to it
twice because I have that's that's how
I've listened to it it's a good book
it's it's the first of the trilogy so
there's two more books after that and
yeah I recommend it and if you want to
get this book itself you can do that by
going to audible.com/smarter cast to 500
500 they also have things like audible
originals which are exclusive audio
titles created by celebrated
storytellers from worlds as diverse as
theatre journalism literature and more
they're pretty sweet it's like audibles
like hey we want to have some sweet
original content too and they're making
it so check it out it's part of your
membership thanks for sticking through
that I do highly recommend checking out
for the sky but in the meantime let's
get back to this podcast and talk with
Andrew and we're back
I recommend that book it's a good one
that was a great ad read I really like
I've never knows those uh it was funny
I've never done that before yeah how
does it feel having a first sponsor it
feels pretty great in that this is okay
I mean a thing that can I mean what is
free cash they reach out to you can ask
did they reach out to you you reached
out to them well we already have a
pre-existing relationship with audibles
so I think it may be flourished out of
that uh I don't actually deal directly
with the brands that's like more of a
Jake and Christian thing right right
yeah let's bring on more quite people
like yourself to the podcast and yeah
just makes it all a little bit a little
bit easier for everybody so I was
curious I got some questions for you oh
did you oh really yeah I know it's card
on now just card oh um you must get hit
up all the time for advertising requests
how do you decide like you know I will
just say no to everything kind of that's
that's a very very oh but that's more
simplification but it's like um I don't
know how much corridor as a company gets
hit up those emails kind of get filtered
out before they reach me but I know I
personally get a hit up a lot of the
time to help out like maybe do some
freelance on the side or like do stuff
and I'm most the time I just like I
don't have the time
energy for that sorry it's usually from
friends being like hey you're someone I
know who does visual effects can you can
you do some visual effects for me and
I'm like listen if I was unemployed I
would take you up on this but I I'm
struggling to find my own time right now
yeah exactly
yeah if it's a if it's like personally
speaking outside of work if it's
something that uh that interests me like
right now I'm learning c40 and octane so
like if it's like hey need us something
rendered is like man I'm doing this in
my free time like course yeah let's go
yeah but otherwise like I usually turn
on most stuff because like I want to
focus on my work here at work you know
and not get too excited about stuff
outside of work I put my my creative
energy here yeah I mean I will accept
some sometimes I'll accept jobs outside
of work but that's mostly just because
it's like I my the most important thing
is that it doesn't impact corridor it's
like is this something I can do in like
a day or two over the weekend I'll do
that sounds like fun yeah yeah yeah
but yeah the vast majority the time I
don't do anything I think that's this
like I listen to a lot of the Tim
Ferriss podcast okay he talks about yeah
here's like top athletes actors I think
he was talking about James Cameron or
something he was talking to like like an
assistant for like a huge director and
his sole job was to say no to people
like it's basically the filter and like
just hundreds of requests a day but he
has to read them because every now and
then they would be like yeah you get the
ones that are worthwhile yeah go on the
Conan show or whatever like where it
would just be like okay this actually
fits with what I know they would want
but their default answer for everything
is no and it has to be no hmm because
otherwise you would get nothing done no
time yeah there's a great book called
the one thing and it's about it's about
that like prioritizing your life in it
and it gives these examples of like
these top like contributors like
scientists who you know most scientists
at best might put out one paper every
three years or so yeah yeah and then
there's this one scientist who does like
six or seven a year
and then that like what does he do
differently and it's like well he he
shuts himself off from the world
he only teaches for like at this
university for three months then he
closes his door everybody knows he's
working and nobody approach and he don't
you go to his website you try to reach
him he says I don't have an email
address because if you if you need to
reach me you already know how to oh snap
yeah it's like it's this idea of like
when you when you let other people
there's another one email is a to-do
list that anyone in the world can add to
mmm oh gosh
which is so true right that one read
emails really yeah it's like dude it's
like is your Gmail just like thousands
it's like four hundred and twenty
thousand or something like that for 20
Wow know what like a lot of like emails
like every time I get a new subscriber
every time I get a new mention on
Twitter that all just goes to my one
email address you know mahkum is red
no it's automatically getting filtered
so but it still adds to my overall email
unread list yeah gmail has got to stop
calling that stuff for us cuz we're not
gonna do it
everybody's got hundreds of thousands of
emails in their Gmail whenever that is
kind of bad at self management of stuff
like that
most of the junk mail though you know
just write stuff it but this is actually
something I wanted to ask you you yeah
you're running polygon right you're hot
you're married mmm good yeah just
turning one in a few days okay okay and
you're you're running your YouTube
blender guru mm-hmm what else
hobbies anything um you have time for
hobbies yeah no I mean I play like an
hour of overwatch okay at night okay
yeah how do you manage all of your stuff
man like what what are your time
management skills like how's that
working for you like how do you do it
how do you do all the things that you
want to do and and raise a family you
know and there's a lot of stuff man I
mean okay so I don't want to pretend
like I've got it all together no one has
it all together I hadn't every single
aspect of my life Raz abled is the
exception
it's it's I feel like you just make room
for it as you go it's like okay I had a
baby and now now this is my weekend like
maybe I'll we can't go out together we
you know baby's gotta go to sleep at
certain times so now I'm just doing this
and that sort of fit in there and then
it's like polygons okay now we've just
launched models and so now we've got a
hire a modeling team and we've got to
manage those models the number of
vertices and you hit a new challenge
like all the artists some of the work
that's that's being released isn't up to
par why did that happen
so then you've got to put in you know
this sort of thing and it just sort of
tags on and along the way what you have
to do is realise when you sort of you're
not using your time optimally right
mm-hmm so replying to YouTube comments
is not the best use of your time because
anybody could do that anybody could
pretend or reply on my behalf or do
something like that that doesn't require
you know the best use of my time what's
the best use of my time is doing the
only thing that I can do that no one
else on my team can do which is YouTube
videos that's the best use of my time in
the last year I've realized I've been so
preoccupied with the polygon stuff I
haven't been able to spend the right
amount of time on YouTube so that was a
time error and inefficiency of my of my
time and it's a yeah it's like it's
asking yourself constantly is this the
best use of my time is this the most
valuable a way to spend my time and
usually it's not promotion of the day
you're doing stuff which is not the best
use of your time but it's like being
aware of it and trying to guide it back
that's what I mean read the book the one
thing that's really good I'd recommend
that so this this professor this writer
this scientist that you were talking
about just now yeah sounds like he
secludes himself
that's his method of dealing with it
right yeah he'll seclude himself he'll
lock the door no email people aren't I'm
not gonna give people a chance to get to
me yeah so the ID sounds like like an
[ __ ] move right and that's the thing
people don't want to
do it they don't want to say that's why
he's saying no to people via email is so
so hot like people like ha I don't know
how do you say no it's like the
alternative is is like well they're the
awesome they were that they were the one
that was basically asking you to give up
some of your time to answer their
request not rude to say that this is my
time and I can hearing it does sound
like it's an [ __ ] proof but it's like
it's not rude to to value or time and
like what I tell people like my way of
saying no is like I it's nothing
personal
as a blanket rule I just don't you know
agree - I don't know book request or or
or whatever because I'm choosing to
focus my time on Blender and polygon so
I can make more tutorials for more
people are always asking for more
tutorials
oh yeah moment you publish to needs tour
they're like alright where's the next
one you're like oh come on come on yeah
the voracious appetite did you do do you
read a lot of books um yeah I I'm one a
month yeah listener I physically read
physically yeah I do really like
physically reading books it's hard to
put aside the time to actually do that
yeah I like I got the Kindle I love the
Kindle yeah so good this is instant you
know I I everyone says it but like I'm
such like a physical book kind of guy
like turn the pages and like you know
making marks in the book and whatnot I
don't like the fact that it's like when
you open the book it's like now you got
this huge stack there and there's tiny
little pain you're gonna like and hold
it down hold it up with your elbow while
you read it it's like I love the king of
it so I recently read the expanse
there's like dreamin the first three
books at least but I read them in
physical book form it's the first time
I'd done that in a very long time
because I got leaves Kindle yeah and it
was like a refreshing experience having
being able to actually turn the pages
but by the end of it I was like I am NOT
going to continue doing that because
it's just like it's so inconvenient
carrying around a big book and then it's
like it's heavy and it's like all the
complaining that I can do about this is
something that you know humanity's never
dealt with so you know whatever but I
I'm gonna stick with just
reading Kindle off my phone because I
got I got a big phone alright you go
nice big screen yes that's good you know
it's backlit thank you and it's usually
way cheap with a Kindle version yeah but
I have been I do the vast majority of my
book reading through listening just
because it's mmm anytime I'm walking my
dog or driving to work half an hour each
way yeah yeah yeah in LA he'd be silly
not to use that that time in the car to
learn something or absolutely so what
would you say uh speaking of learning
what would you say are your top three
non-fiction books for like bettering
your life oh well I mean it's not like
one size fits all but like okay if you
want to get into business you want to
have your own thing I highly recommend
the e-myth terrible name for a book
Emeth the e-myth which stands for the
entrepreneurial myth oh I thought it was
like electronic I meant no that's why it
says we don't write as give I have this
360 camera that I'd put on a pole and
Clint's always saying you got your East
staff that's like it's like an
electronic like Gandalf staff hilarious
so II the Emeth for yes so some people
who want to do business what it what it
what it distills is like look number one
reason that most especially if you're an
artist I recommend that book because so
many artists all like if you're a chef
if you're good at what you do the the
book uses this analogy of like there's a
pie maker right she makes really good
pies and all her friends say you
shouldn't open up a pie store I say she
like I'll open up a pie stall cuz she
has a pie store and then he's like two
years later she's like not being able to
pay the bills she gets into work at like
5:00 a.m. she leaves at like midnight
her life is a mess and it's like what's
happened is that she is a technician a
technician meaning like she does the
technical work she does the thing that
you're selling but to be a successful
business person you have to give that up
to somebody else you have to release the
reins you have to be good at delegating
and to delegate you have to be able to
communicate like how do you make a good
pie because if I just give it to a bunch
of
chefs and say all right you do the pie
thing they're gonna mess it up so it's
like the book it explains very well
which I haven't seen any other book do
very well is like for an artist for uh
for somebody who does the work it's so
hard to give that up yeah um but it
gives the real example that like if you
don't you won't succeed most small
businesses will fail for this very
reason then you're good at this one
thing and now you made it your business
and it's not gonna work like that you
have to be able to show up hire other
people to do the thing because otherwise
the business isn't gonna run itself like
somebody has to run the business and
that's your role if you want to be a
technique if you just like making pies
go work for somebody who makes pies
right they and it's it's a like it's an
uncomfortable read if you are especially
if you've run a business where you're
that's currently you it'll be a very
uncomfortable read is that how you felt
yeah I mean anyone who reads it will be
like oh no this is me this is how I do
this too much you know but it's it's the
alternative is you just don't read it
and then your business will fail or
whatever you know yeah so how did how
did you go from like starting polygon
right and you enjoy working in 3d you
enjoy being in blender and then you have
you have to pass that off to somebody
else like what was that like yeah I mean
we'll say it was before polygon I see so
blender guru like we started make the
first product I ever made was an e-book
which I wrote and um it was a success
and it made enough money that I could
quit my job I was a debt collector at
Toyota really oh I would call I wasn't
the physical one I'm not big enough to
be this but to say but I would call him
up on the phone and get you got you got
pay that sounds stressful man you get
one a day one a day which would go
mental at you and you go alright that's
my one a day but everyone else was most
people I just like oh I'd like to pay
yeah I bet most people already know yeah
it's just like facing reality like oh
gosh yeah yeah okay but then you mean
better than dreading
yeah but then you have those guys that
yeah they've they man some people the
it just it opened my my world to like
the fact that people just take on
incredible amounts of debt not realizing
the paperwork because they're like yeah
but I got that truck that's mine now and
it's like dude the interest you're
paying is insane like they're defaulting
on like that the second payment it's
like dude that sounds stressful yeah now
Ben so you sold your first book yeah so
so my first book I quit my job at Toyota
and then I it was the name of that book
by the way the wow factor wow factor
forty seven dollars each was expensive
Wow that's that's like a textbook yeah
but it was basically like 20 tutorials
rolled into one it was like teaching you
how to do the like color grading glow
glare specular highlights you know send
blender or and blend up yeah yeah okay
so anyway so I did that and then I think
my second one was the nature Academy
which was even bigger thing that was
like a series of video tutorials with
free models so like plant models tree
models like textures of bark that kind
of thing and I was taking all those
photos myself and I made the plants
myself and then for the next probably
may was the architecture Academy and
that was when I started hiring people to
help me build the assets because we had
we wanted to make like a library of
furniture and textures and it's
basically the polygon of today gotcha
know at what point in that process did
you read EEMA 'the just recently oh but
you started figuring that out way back
then though that like hey you can't do
all this on your own you have to get
some help and that was when you started
delegating away some of that technical
work yeah I actually my dad gave me a
course he bought me for Christmas like
this internet marketing course okay in
Australia and it was like a I don't know
a three-day thing or something like that
but I I learned what was possible and
something that they taught a lot in the
course was like you got to have a VA
virtual assistant in high one in the
Philippines super cheap and they're
really good and and I'm like no I'm not
gonna do that
no you need one like wow it's like who's
handling your emails I'm like of course
it's me it's like no how are you gonna
do that when you get to this
scale-like you have to start delegating
and it kind of like drilled into me that
the value of being able to hire people
and then that's taken care of and then
that is what will enable you to do what
you do well maybe make a better product
because the thing is like if you if you
were just like answering email all day
think of the disservice you're doing to
the customers that you aren't making the
next product or you're not doing a free
update for that thing that they all
bought like you could be giving real
value to the masses of people but
because you're answering a single email
you're not doing that well that's a huge
disservice to all these hundreds of
thousands of other people you know yeah
it's like if corridor was - yeah
answer every email that got sent in or
every YouTube comment like how frequent
would you upload to be every other
decade or so yeah exactly right so
that's a whereas when you're uploading
regularly you're bringing satisfaction
to the masses right you know it's like
that's like when you put it in that that
context it's one or the other well then
obviously that's the that's the smart
one so how far along doing all those
things did you get the inspiration to
start polygons yeah it was polygons
spelled with two eyes by the way
two eyes so is it polygons no I just
probably like Pillai Egon I know what
every name is taken you know I totally
hear you dude I spent like a week going
through all the different names to name
the company and it was like so it had to
be something which was related to 3d but
wasn't so targeted that it would like
limit us in the future
yeah like if we just made it like
textures calm that's roars like blender
3d textures dot code exactly yeah you
know like then what we're gonna start
selling 3ds max it doesn't fit the name
anymore so it's like and eventually I
realized like you have to go with a
misspelling you have to do the typical
startup thing remove a letter add a
letter change the letter yeah pull it on
and then I didn't even know that then
polygon is a big company with a why pol
why gon it's that big like game yeah
journalism company journalist yeah like
gamer B's and it was like ah that's
annoying oh well
but yeah so real quick I just for those
of you watching or listening who don't
know anything about 3d modeling or
texturing or lighting or anything like
that I want to quickly just break down
what a texture is because most of the
time when people think I'm just gonna
slap a texture onto that they think that
you just take a picture of like a
cardboard or something mm-hmm and apply
it to a box and that's it and they just
think that like maybe that picture is
being wrapped around a box but it's so
much more than that because it's not
just a picture it's it's like light
interacts with cardboard or wood or any
material for that matter this carpet
here in very different ways and there's
lots of different channels within that
texture that dictate that so I mean do
you want to kind of break down what
makes like what are all the shaders
within a single texture yeah yeah for
sure so basically for for every texture
so let's say let's use the example of a
wood table right there's the color right
and that's the one everyone knows it's
what you would get if you were to stand
over it with an iPhone and take a photo
of a wood table you'd see the color of
it and that that color includes like all
the oranges and yellows and even the
black yeah like a grain everything that
you would see with the well yeah it
should be just the raw color of like the
actual material underneath it then on
top of that you have got gloss gloss or
roughness those are that so that is a
map called the glottal roughness map
they are interchangeable terms they're
just inverts of each other some software
uses roughness some software use of
cloth but the same thing just inverted
where roughness guys over here like you
glossy guess over there yeah and that
one is determining how sharp the
reflection is so a mirror obviously is
the sharpest of all reflection because
chrome yeah chrome that's super sharp
whereas raba is one of the most diffuse
you wouldn't see your reflection in
rubber because it's so smeared out but
there is amazingly the same amount of
reflection in rubber as there isn't a
mirror it's a dielectric material I
should mean that it's not metal which
like Chrome that would be something else
but it has it's like the same amount of
reflection it's just like spread out in
such a large way on the rubber
it looks like you're not seeing
reflection but they ease reflection I
hear so it's like when you have a mirror
the light ray is bouncing off of that
mirror and heading right back at you
yeah and that's a very sharp angle or
the more rough it is or the less glossy
it is that roughness or sorry that
reflection angle kind of gets more and
more outwards until it's like rubber
where it's like hitting it and then
directly going sideways yeah is that
kind of yeah it would I mean I got make
sure I say it correctly but yeah it's
like the more porous something is the
more the rays are just gonna bounce off
in random directions okay
so like a brick or a concrete or
something like that you don't seen the
reflection so like bouncing around I'm
sure I'm missing something out that is
anyway current from specular like a
specular map right
so that is the confusion specular was
the old workflow okay well you had to
tell the rendering engine how much
reflection this thing should have now we
don't use the specular as much anymore
okay shouldn't be used really if you're
using a metallic work for this is
getting like really like inside baseball
but it's like yeah there's like so PBR
physically based rendering yeah yeah it
is that came along I mean it it's been
around for a while but I guess like the
last three or five years it sort of
started to pop up most rendering engine
sorry most game engines now use use PBR
and a lot of other remarkably still some
offline renderers don't handle like a
metallic workflow
I think V Ray's one could be totally
wrong on their ID using v-ray I didn't
like it there's a lot of reasons but
anyway yeah there's a there's a it
wasn't gonna say oh yeah so the specular
the specular map was there to show like
how much how much reflectivity this
surface should have but reflectivity is
different to the roughness of the
reflection so a dielectric material
that's a technical term but it basically
is like 90 percent of materials because
this is a material that is not metal so
in the real world there is two types of
materials there is a dielectric material
and there is a metal material okay and
metal or it's not yeah a maximum
Tara would have could have higher ranges
of like index of refraction which would
be like the reflectivity where's the
dielectric material he's gonna have by
default the index of refraction would be
one point four five which is like the
base I mean it could be slightly more
slightly less okay but that is the base
of it which means the reflectivity
should be the same so that's what I mean
like rubber and this wooden table tile
that will all have the same reflection
the differences in its reflectivity
appearance would be in the gloss the
glossy metal the rubbing sense how rough
it actually looks so that's why when you
use a proper proper shader that accounts
for this so we've got one in blend at
the principle of ESD F based on this
Disney shader system which works
amazingly
you just keep the specular values and
it's there if you want artistic control
but you should just leave it and then
you just tweak the roughness depending
on if it's paper turn the roughness all
the way up if it is Crum turn all the
way down you know the way I've always
liked us describing like roughness
versus glossy or not necessarily
roughness for skies but like no
roughness versus full roughness is like
a Christmas ornament one of those like
nice reflective red Christmas balls and
rank up the roughness suddenly it's a
frosted yes Christmas ball yes it's more
and more frosted more rough against yes
exactly that's a good yeah so beyond
that we have now we have to tell the
light what angle it's hitting it so we
use normal maps we used to use bump maps
mm-hmm and a bump map is basically just
a map that tells the renderer the
geography topography topography of an
object or material but now we use normal
Maps now why is that what is a normal
map okay so a normal map is okay so I
will be honest I have heard that there
is a difference between a bump map and a
normal map so a bump map was just black
and white I'm like a might map and it
would just go up and down the normal map
from my understanding has an extra axes
in it I understand how that would work
I think it kind of distinguishes like
which direction a slope is kind of
facing let's say you have like a hill
and or like a big bump in the middle of
your texture like one side of it will be
purple the other side will be
Green and then there's one more color
and it kind of just distinguishes like a
little bit more accuracy yeah the
direction that's true you probably right
yeah yeah it kind of gives a little bit
more fidelity to to a bump as opposed to
just like up and down mm-hmm yeah yeah
it's it but essentially in its what I
mean
I've yeah you can switch between a black
and white bump map and then a normal map
if you had them both and they kind of
look pretty similar it's not that big of
a change but anyways normal map is the
established standard it's a purple
looking map you always identify it there
it is that's the purple that's the
purple one that's the one I got to use
and you're gonna put it in the right
spot and there it is and it gives you
bump so wood grain right it's the grain
so that as you run your fingers your
nails across the wood you would feel the
little bumps that's what it's detecting
and it typically makes it a material of
awesome moment you a deer like aha
lovely yeah yeah
and then the final map is displacement
which is related to is also my favorite
map yeah
displacement map is my favorite mainly
just because what we use octane render
uh-huh utilizes displacement Maps better
than I think most renderers now I don't
use cycle do you primarily use cycles
which is a myself yeah the prep prep
Pratt that proprietary blender renderer
I think its proprietary its open-source
oh okay I meant like it's like the main
one that blender use a default one like
the d-pad it is like so the difference
between say a normal map is that in a
displacement map is that a displacement
displacement map actually displaces the
geometry of the render so whereas a
normal map if you put that on like a
sphere of like say a rocky pebble
material right like a gravel road when
you're looking straight at the the
sphere like in the center of it
with a light at a certain angle you can
change the angle of that light and it'll
look like the light is wrapping around
the pebbles correctly but when you look
towards the edges of the sphere you can
still see that it's that sphere is
perfectly smooth yeah you can it kind of
gives away the illusion a little bit it
because at the end of the day it is a
little bit of a hack you know it's kind
of just hacking together
oh this it's supposed to look this bumpy
whereas a displacement map legitimately
make
that bumpy it yes it pushes out or pulls
in the geometry and that octane that
that happens at the render level is not
actually moving the polygons themselves
of the 3d model mm-hmm
because back in the day displacement
maps weren't used because you would have
to put so many polygons in your mouth
you'd have to subdivide it to the point
that like your 3d model was like a
couple gigabytes just be able to
displace those polygons but now with a
displacement map at least in octane
probably other renders these days - it
just happens after rendering levels you
can have just a few polygons but you
still have like really nice finest
displacement yeah I think it's got
different names but micro displacement
might be the term it's used - yeah
define that yeah when it goes to the
rendering stage that's when it starts
displacing things okay yeah yeah but yes
sir I guess to explain to the viewers
like the normal map that we were
mentioning doesn't add anything to the
render times which makes it amazing okay
we don't got like ya know three
rendering time I've just got you went
from a service that looks flat and
boring you put a normal map on it and it
just looks amazing because it's for it
because the geometry of the thing didn't
change the little tiny wood grains and
the little bumps that's not actually
there it's just the illusion of it
that's why I think I tweeted wise it's
like the guy who discovered the normal
map must have been jumping up and down
like oh my god
we've just created like an infinite
amount of detail for free I think they
were originally developed for video
games like ten years ago I think yeah
maybe maybe a little bit more than 15
years ago cuz it's like they're trying
to get more detail in their video game
assets but of course you know you run
off consoles or old pcs at the time
they're kind of limited in terms of
power so it's like we got to squeeze
more ability out of our limited
resources and ya end up with normal Maps
and that kind of changed the game for a
lot of 3d games yeah one thing I love
about your tutorials is the fact that
you know where to save time like and all
these little spots like you're saying
with the normal maps are free free
render timings yeah like that's so
that's so invaluable to me like to be
able to know hey guys we gotta save all
the time here cuz time is money time is
very valued so like well where where do
you where like are you just constantly
looking for areas - I don't say cut
corners but like
you looking for four areas to you know
save time here and there in all aspects
when you're working in 3d or does that
expand out into and like your same with
emails the delegating stuff uh-huh
uh-huh
so yeah but how you're trying to save
time how do you save time how do you say
more - I mean it's honestly it depends
on the project like so I just made this
kitchen tutorial which I upload a couple
weeks go great tutorial by the way oh
thank you yeah oh nice she said okay um
and that one because I did an animation
through it I had to cut those render
times down hmm
and because render times were like 24
minutes per frame
oof that's that's unacceptable with two
gtx 980ti
okay yeah it was it was really long and
I was like oh my god and then I remade
the scene so I just open up a new scene
and I remade it from scratch I got the
like and then when I was remaking
because I know everything they said this
is a cool trick like if you're making
anything even just for the sake of like
you're not making a tutorial you've just
finished something a finished scene if
you just start a new file and you remade
it sounds like a lot of work but it's
actually you'll get it done in like a
tenth of the time because you know what
you're doing um you will discover so
many errors in the original one like a
map that wasn't in the right spot a
feature that you turned on that you're
not using anymore but it's now adding 50
percent more render time you'll you'll
go like okay now I'm doing the lighting
hmm I've got an HDR in this is that the
right age to you there you go what if it
looks better without the HDI what if it
what if I try and you do both of them
and that was when I discovered for this
kitchen one that HD ours were doubling
my render times and it wasn't adding
anything to the thing I went what but is
to say well that saved half the render
time there and then it was like then I
had to learn to yeah the trees
I had these trees in the background
trees although that that is a problem to
solve
at polygon we want to try to make a tree
which actually looks good but renders
fast and like you look around online
like all trees are just so complex it's
it's like the worst asset that every
because trees are everywhere if you're
doing any
sort of seen even in interior because
you've got trees outside trees are
everywhere you won't find a place on
earth that you really can't see trees
only students in the desert was like
this so complex and they so dense and if
the camera is moving obviously you can
tell if it's a title card like if it's
if it's a static card like a flat yeah
this of paper exactly so you often need
geometry if the camera is close enough
to it but in this case I realized that
yeah if you render it just on a on a
plane
the movement wasn't in like that bad
that you couldn't that it was okay to
have that so anyway like I I don't do
that all the time like I don't like
optimize things down to like crush it as
low as I can go but in this case I was
sort of forced to if I was just doing a
still frame I probably just would have
left everything as it is yeah yeah so
you were in the need where you needed
the same time yeah exactly
your format mine right now though that's
crazy so you build the scene you do the
thing you're like sweet all right 24
minutes like I gotta cut some time down
so you start a new new project and you
redo it I typically do it three to four
times
that's so cool tutorial yeah it's like
we make it from scratch three or four
times yeah when you like it's like when
the power goes out you lose and you
forgot to save you know and it's like oh
no I lost all my work to do it all over
again like whatever you were doing
whether it's sound design or 3d or
editing so you're saying to go back you
go back and you do it again and you're
gonna do it in like a third of the time
yeah oh yeah you'll do it really far and
you will just discover so many things
that would make it better
what add is awesome examples of things
you do not compromise in terms of time
like I mean I know you're saying that
you don't like necessarily try to make
every step along the way super efficient
but what are things that no matter how
much time you have to save what are what
are some examples of things that you're
like this this is just how it is
it cannot get any faster than this
because I refuse to let go of a certain
amount of quality yeah or whatever mom
in the image right yeah yeah yeah um I
mean I typically go for photo realism
right and to get photo real entity to a
or at least aim for it yeah you don't
always get that but you
aim for it and to do that you have to
that there are certain things that like
if the camera was close enough to that
tree for one of the shots who actually
was so I just need use the real tree
then I would have to use the tree
because I don't want something that's
gonna break the image mhm right so
that's it's it's discovering what you
what you're gonna what you can't
compromise on when you actually reach it
you know like what's another example
yeah like the geometry like having
physical displacement across something
that is typically you obviously need a
lot more of a denser mesh to have
something like if you've got like a
dirty like ground with rocks and all
that kind of stuff on it and then you
want to use a displacement map on it
you've got to have more geometry cuz
otherwise you're gonna have like little
spikes in octane you don't have to have
that really okay dense geometry okay
because it's happening like after the
fact I can have like a single polygon
like a four-sided four edged polygon and
throw a nice displacement map over it
and it'll like look pretty good but then
in that case it must be doing it's
probably some blazing it or subdividing
it but it's happening at the render
level and it's happening pretty fast
yeah but the the the mesh would still be
there what it could be doing so we have
just got it in blender as well adaptive
subdivision whereby the closer the it is
to the camera the more it will subdivide
it and then the further in the
background it will be less and less
interesting okay yeah like decimates it
as it's needed it's really cool hmm it
could be doing that I I don't even use
octane but and granted I don't know
enough about how it works behind the
scenes to know if I'm actually telling
the truth about that but I'm pretty
certain because I can get some pretty
really fast results like it it renders
really fast mmm with retains pretty fast
isn't I've heard it's fast in general
yeah yeah but I've always found its use
of displacement mapping to be its
strongest feature mm-hmm its redshift
available for cinema 4d yes yes have you
used it no my friend uses redshift he
swears by it and I swear I I really want
to do a video doing a render engine
comparison uh-huh because I feel like oh
man everybody's using a render engine
because they sort of preferred or they
do this but like I haven't seen any
actual like breakdown of the same scene
and each rendering engine like Corona
everybody uses that in architecture yeah
yeah it's cpu-based only oh yeah which
is why but they're like we're proudly
cpu-based am i proud proud about that
good yeah no but I supposedly proudly
still starting my fires by rubbing two
sticks
proudly yeah what do you say to the guys
who don't have time to save time I mean
no it's that's understandable in like if
you're on uh on on a deadline and you've
like literally got to just get this out
it could be cheaper to just put it out
immediately because we've gotta have
this out in five hours and then send it
to the render farm and you just throw
money at it to solve that problem
mmm because you can yeah like the same
image I house us into a talk by a guy
who worked on Star Wars and he said he
saved them seventy thousand dollars by
for their renders like cuz they had
stuff in the background of these shots
and they were rendering them at 4k or
whatever that was needed and he's like
it's in the background it's out of focus
let's render it at a quarter of the size
and then just blur it and he couldn't
tell the difference and he saved them
seventy thousand dollars or something
it's like no like because we're doing
YouTube videos you know we do that sort
of thing all the time
that's just thing baby falls that's
normal you know like I'm gonna be adding
fast blur to that anyway I'm gonna
render that at 720p
part of me I understand it's like Ren
Ren you're like do 500 samples and then
turn on the denoiser I'm like yeah it's
not gonna be as good if I do like
thousand samples yeah yeah cuz it feels
like sometimes it feels like cheating
it's like I cut lower the bar too much
and I lower lower the quality in my mind
you know and it's like but even though
it's you know I lower I lower all these
settings like it still feels like it
can't be is it's not as good as it could
be you know and I get stuck on that
sometime you know but being that
professional is it's delivering work
it's it's being able to like I I think
that's actually like a good thing like
there are some artists you see on like
odd station although you know
elsewhere online and they just do like
amazing photo-realistic work but they
released like one artwork a year hmm and
it's like yet that was obviously a
personal project and they spent forever
on and it looks amazing because it
should but that's not it's not feasible
in a in a work environment and most
important thing an artist can do is just
finish finish exactly as you can you can
work on something forever you will
always find things that you can perfect
or change or enhance or polish but at a
certain point you obviously you have a
lot of diminished returns at a certain
point and pretty much our entire
business model here at corridor is
finding that exact moment where we start
having diminished returns where it's
like it's taken too much effort to make
this slightly better let's just yeah
let's move on so do you have you've got
like a schedule for like do you know
like the next three videos you're gonna
do next five next five yeah okay which
six well the record usually isn't quite
the case we're usually we usually know
what like the next two videos will
probably be rarely five videos we're
stepping up this year how many video is
he delivering this year
well what's half of 51 2024 I don't know
usually one every two weeks that's the
plan man that's what we did last year
and I think that's kind of in our plan
forever with like since the beginning of
corridor their plan was put out a new
video every other week the challenge is
maintaining that there are times works
like we end up kind of breaking into
seasons where we'll go a couple months
without uploading anything other times
like Sammy Nico will leave to go do some
sort of YouTube bread show and it's like
all right our workforce is now cut in
half obviously we can't maintain that
same schedule that's impressive
it's only possible with the team that
you've because like most I mean there's
a lot of like really good successful
youtubers who had too much of a
perfectionist and you notice that they
upload stop being like every two months
every three months every that was me man
really oh yeah my pony sure Channel yeah
I was like eight months for carbon
warfare 2 freaking a year for this year
for that and then it's like I'm not
gonna be able to sustain a channel a
business no way with that kind of thing
you know I can't just draw
every once in a while going all-in so
you really perfect your artistic vision
but even within that you still are like
having to end it end it and that's what
I'm saying it is like the most important
thing an artist can do is be like all
right this is done it is finished I'm
hitting the render button I'm hitting
the export button I've hit the upload
button whatever it is that you do to
like conclude the project nothing is
more important than that yeah like I
would say this like because we get a lot
of like portfolios that polygon okay and
if we see one where they have done like
one or two really amazing pieces of
artwork but you can see looking at their
time and that's they worked on it for a
year that's less impressive than
somebody who got like 70 80 percent of
the way but they've been doing regular
work or especially when there's been for
a client because you know that a client
had a deadline and a budget and they
couldn't deliver on that because like
that's the thing if you want to if you
want to do this as a job you have to
realize that you're no longer an artist
anymore you're what you're creating is
what if there was a commodity but it's
like there there's an expense to the
amount of time you're spending on
something and the client has a budget
you have to meet that budget and telling
them all but is it will be so much
better if I could spend five more days
on it they don't give a [ __ ] it's your
job to make it work as well as you can
the best you can within the timeframe
hmm it's like one of the like the best
guys we've had work for us was somebody
who would like we would tell him the
deadline and he'd be like all right and
he would do what he could within that
and you'd find out that he cut corners
everywhere he could because he had to
meet he didn't ever come to us and go
sorry gonna need another two days
another three days
you never said he was always ready at
the right time because that is the mark
of a professional that is it uh-huh
it's like it's you have to be able to do
that you have to be able to release but
being a perfectionist it's overrated
it's really overrated and if you look at
I talked about it in I've got to talk on
YouTube the seven Habits of Highly
Effective artists you can't watch it in
America
really for some reason it's got a
trademark and the the creators are like
it was I did it at the blender
conference and so it's posted to the
blender each account it's got two
million views but you can't find it in
America dude you guys send it to us man
because that sounds good I don't want to
watch but yeah I think it's because I
used the title the seven Habits of
Highly Effective artists based off that
book yeah by Stephen Covey's I think
it's a trademarked name well that's well
anyways you can just type in the name
I'm sure somebody's reuploaded it
whatever but anyway I talked about like
why being a perfectionist isn't good you
think being a perfectionist works to
your advantage but I she doesn't like
top hardest the top artists in history
like like Picasso you know him for like
a few paintings if you look at his work
like he's done thousands like hunt like
it was something like 1000 1500 like
tapestries I was like several thousand
paintings several thousand sketches just
the volume of work is insane but you
only know him for a few things and
biting his era or something like that
ripping his ear off I don't and the
other and it was which book it was from
but yeah we're saying like they they had
a look at the composers like Mozart
Beethoven all those the top composers
them there's a direct correlation
between the volume of work they produced
and the number of hits they had the more
the higher the volume of work they
produced a greater chance they had of
having a hit you don't know which one's
gonna become a hit which one's gonna
like ain't that the truth where I never
know which is successful yeah tell us a
video that you were surprised it didn't
have as good as success as oh gosh all
of them oh yeah no no no that's I mean
there's a couple videos that we put a
lot of effort into I know a few years
ago we did a video called drone star
wars which we thought was so epic it was
using like really cool new filmmaking
through drone racing and we put like a
whole Star Wars theme behind it we're
like this video is gonna be I'm a
successful video of all time and it
performed like average I was like okay
we did a video last year called anime
fest and the Furious and that was a
video we put a lot of time into and we
thought was really cool really epic and
it also just kind of performed average
hmm a self-driving car yeah yeah yeah
and uh then yeah but then it's like
we'll do a video where uh Sam's like hey
what if we just like try to make like a
GTA video just like walk around like
punch people in the face like pretend
obviously it's a video and we'll spend
the week on it or let's shoot a video on
an iPhone where we pretend to have a
lightsaber that doesn't stop growing
just like blows up and it's like well I
think it was the thumbnail for that
coming because I saw that in my fade
with the the plane chopped and I'm like
I gotta see that yeah we put I mean yeah
it's like we put a lot of effort into
our thumbnails and yeah that's lame to
the folks you've got a guy whose
full-time job is thumbnails basically
yeah that's Gabe shadow on it the
audience knows Gabe he's pretty much
like the biggest sweetheart of a grizzly
bear he's like he's so soft-spoken but
like really talented and he he has a lot
of responsibilities as we all do but
like his biggest responsibility is
making thumbnails because at the end of
the day the thumbnail and title is the
barrier to entry to anyone viewing a
YouTube video it's like that is like the
filter to anyone the video can be
amazing or it can be terrible it doesn't
matter there's not the biggest
correlation between how good a video is
and how many views it is as much as
there is a between how good the
thumbnail and title is no news it has
right so it's like if we can make our
thumbnails better and it's not just a
quality thing either it's like it's not
it's like does this grab an audience's
eye at like just such a small little
like postage stamp-sized is in title
enticing enough about being to click
Beatty and all that stuff yeah really
really hard it is actually yeah I was I
was gonna ask you guys how you go about
making this numbness maybe I should talk
to it Gabe yeah yeah yeah it was like
some of our older videos that maybe
didn't perform very well like anime fast
and furious for instance that used to be
called anime self-driving cars and we
did two things after the video had like
500,000 views after like a couple months
I think I have more than that when we
went back and we changed
the title to anime fest and furious a
little bit more of a known IP a little
bit more relatable a more relatable and
we change the thumbnail to be I think a
little bit more ridiculous even and
within a week got another million views
whoa just doing that so it was like
basically holy crap certain degree was
like free exposure and free money just
by doing a small little change and
suddenly the video got a lot more
viewership just off of that a little bit
of effort that's crazy yeah what'd you
think of the amount of people that
worked on that video and like all the
acting the lighting the grip the gap all
are coming doesn't matter if the
thumbnail wasn't right yeah double the
results by tweaking one little tiny
thing it's so important isn't it yes
we've been going back and trying to like
identify like maybe like our bottom like
30 percent performing videos and just
like changing the thumbnail and title on
them and seeing what happens like we did
a video last year uh I guess this is
technically before your time but it was
the son Brett dressed up as a zombie I
was like a zombie Matador type video and
that video got like maybe three hundred
thousand views and like at the end of
the year we had changed the thumbnail in
title and I think that video is sitting
at like five or six million views now
whoa
yeah that is crazy you know when you say
you change it to like fast and furious
so ever a danger of that IP guy coming
taking money from you like D monetizing
a video I mean I don't think that I mean
in a title I don't think that's possible
if they did make a stink about it we
could just change the name of it but I
don't think they even have the right to
that mm-hmm I don't this is that this is
a question for Jake I'm not going to be
familiar with like copyright law or
anything like that okay yeah I think
it's okay yeah yeah yeah so going back
to quantity and consistency versus being
a perfectionist right you think that is
the key to getting better at a craft and
to honing in your skills and being a
professional is consistency yeah yeah
but okay so here's the thing though
there there has to be you can go too far
okay okay yeah I don't think daily
renders are a good idea what about what
I'm not a people fan I do like people's
work he's a standout outlier in the case
that he is
he does do amazing professional work on
the side and he does these uh these
videos which are really high polish yeah
you can tell the difference between that
and his daily renders yeah these daily
renders you can tell it took a day
mm-hmm
the trouble with I think a day Rena is
that if you limit yourself down too far
there's only so much for one there's
only so much you can do but also you're
gonna limit how far you'll explore into
things challenges right because it like
what's something you want you're not
good at in 3d like not your strong suit
hair modeling modeling modeling a
character animating animating dude
okay animating yeah so if I gave you a
day to do something light and you had to
deliver something at the end of the day
you're not gonna do that
exactly but to be a good artist you
gotta challenge yourself yes we gotta
learn these new things so a day is too
short of a time I think a week is good
because I think you can do a lot in a
week you're not gonna be able to make a
short film you're not gonna be able to
pull that off maybe yeah but a week for
for a single image to do it properly I
think that's enough time now but that I
mean it's enough time to make like a
good image and learn something but like
how productive is that we cuz we can't
really do that here at corridor works
like I'm gonna spend a week making an
images lay alright alright yeah like
what if what if someone's job is to do
an image everyday for someone's
Instagram right yeah you render yeah
what do you tell them like what do you
what do you say like hey you know you
need to expand you need to reach outside
of the box and you need to challenge
yourself but they only have a day so
what do you do if they only have a day
and they have a day or a week you know
dependent it's just the scale like they
have to deliver a month's worth in a
week or they have to deliver right well
I mean in that case you've got to pull
from you got to find ways to to cut down
that time like I think people uses
several asset libraries he doesn't model
the cars and the buildings and all that
stuff in and he just pulls from it so
you gotta get good at that and I think
yeah you definitely would get good at
figuring where to cut corners to make
something look bigger than it actually
was using back
plates instead of rendering the full
scene yeah I mean yeah I don't I don't
make it sound like daily renders oh like
it like a terrible idea that you will
learn but the trouble is is for a
beginner it's a terrible piece of advice
to tell people to do a deadly Brenda
because and they say this for like like
when I was learning painting and drawing
and I I messaged a bunch of like famous
painters and drawers and things my I
told them I'm gonna spend six months
learning drawing and painting I want to
get good at it and I got a series of
questions can I ask you some questions
like yeah I said what's a top like what
is a common mistake people have when
they come to like painting or drawing
and some guy says something I'll always
remember it he said speed painting is
terrible advice for a beginner there's
lots of pros that put out these videos
where they show they painted this
environment and took them they do it in
like one hour yeah for a beginner that's
horrible because if you try to do that
you're you're not gonna understand what
you're doing you're not gonna know where
you can cut corners and you're gonna
adopt sloppy habits so if you're just
learning 3d and you're doing a daily
render you're gonna have sloppy habits
your materials aren't gonna be perfect
because you don't know materials you
don't understand all the maps and all
that kind of thing you're not gonna have
the right lighting that the colors gonna
be off you're gonna make so many
mistakes repeatedly if you got feedback
on each of those images from like like
if you're in a class and the professor
or the top teacher whatever for the name
tutors whatever was like there to give
you feedback on every image I think it's
valuable I like you could we could learn
from that yeah most people aren't in a
position where they can have regular
feedback yeah yeah people want a solo on
the guitar mm-hmm but they need to learn
their scales first
yeah the fundamentals so what are the
fundamentals of 3d what are the scales I
think it's actually good to to to break
it off and do like yes spend spend the
right time on like okay so modeling is
the foundation of the building okay
right if you have to go to wrong model
it's not gonna look good yes got like
not enough Paules and you got like one
key bits doesn't matter what its gonna
look like crap yes you gonna learn good
modeling modeling now is less about
Pauly's and like what was it called poly
modeling yeah poly modeling like when I
started I maybe when you guys started it
was like doing things Paul D by poly
model things that's less the case now
it's more ZBrush and then retopo like
because it used to be so important to
have like a really like modeling
something out of digital clay would be
ZBrush right exactly yeah yeah and you
start with like you just go zebra and
just go all extreme poly like high poly
counts but then you just retopo it
automatically with zremesh or something
like that but it allows you to work
creatively
um but yeah like like okay so if you
want to be a like if you want to make
characters the best thing you could
learn is Anatomy learn the anatomy of
the face like so many character models I
see they just don't know the anatomy and
therefore it looks looks wrong and they
might say oh but it's stylized
but don't do stylized yeah you're not
there because you need to have good
anatomy in stylization as well it's like
you have to know what the rules are
before you know how to break them
exactly exactly yeah so that yeah so
that's the modeling and then once you've
got a good model then you probably want
to learn how to I mean lighting or
texturing depends which one you go for
but texturing that's that's obviously
learning what shaders do like if you're
making a face like where you should have
like I don't know like like what's the
albedo and then like the wrinkles like
that kind of thing like using substance
painter that kind of you can go really
deep into texturing and then lighting
sorry what do you mean by albedo wrote
like oh diffuse lit the color map he'll
the color map yeah they call all the
gloss the bum all that stuff we've
talked about and then yeah lighting I'm
I'm actually about to do like a series
on um like design theory cool so like
lighting composition and color and then
maybe if I can figure it out visual
hierarchy that's a new thing a lot can
we expect those videos next week maybe
once you have a CEO you can uh yeah any
more on that yeah that's right I love
your Theory videos man thanks very
well-structured
well-thought-out well delivered in it
thanks
yeah I enjoy making them because I have
to learn it myself to make the video
yeah and I discover all this stuff extra
level yeah it's fun yeah I Castle yeah
hmm well I think it's about that time
that we start wrapping this up what what
about deep fakes oh oh oh that's right
okay we had a conversation over the
weekend where you mentioned that you
didn't think deep fakes are gonna be a
big deal and I was like wha but then I
had it like what's deeper we have to
save this conversation for the podcast
so here we are yeah deep fakes are a
thing that have come out over the last
year or two which is basically an image
processing effect that uses machine
learning to help make really realistic
face but at the end of the day basically
just means transplanting someone's face
onto the body of someone else in a video
or an image or something in us remapping
all the facial features to that person's
face no matter how they're moving their
head in what it comes down to is you can
literally make anyone do anything or say
anything at the end of the day have you
seen the video of Obama saying stuff and
he's talking and it's actually voiced by
Jordan Peele it looks like he's saying
it but he's not
is it a key and Peele skit no it was
actually for BuzzFeed oh no I've never
seen that video okay it sort of went
viral and that was sort of the trigger
that everyone freaked out because it was
people like oh you could use this like
politically to make a politician say
something whoa yeah because this is what
yeah exactly you can you can make anyone
you want you can put them in a really
difficult position where it's like I can
make this person be amongst really
racist people saying really racist
things when that person is not a racist
but there's video evidence now of them
doing this and it destroys any
foundation of trust because that person
especially now can be like oh but that
is fake and before deep fakes were
things like well what are you talking
about no one can do that obviously it's
not fake but now not only can you do
that and put them in a pickle position
they can deny it and be like no it's
fake even if it is a real video mm-hmm
videos not authentic that video of me
baby yeah that's somebody faked it so so
here's the thing right you don't think
it's a big deal I don't think I think
the media is doing what they're very
good at which is making people scared of
new technology that is fair they do that
okay so for starters it's not new okay
the ability to make somebody say
something
Forrest Gump came out in 1994 mmm-hmm
that had politicians saying and doing
stuff that was not them obviously that
was 94 okay so the difference is they
needed a huge team of very skilled
artists to make that look real whereas
now it can be done by thirteen year old
on use a little crappy computer yeah
okay so it's not new it's just that the
the barrier to entry is now so much
lower
okay but you still have a huge challenge
ahead of you okay to make something to
look real okay so if I was to to
Photoshop someone doing something in you
you could probably fool a lot of people
right you could put it in front of like
a photo expert a forensic puss and have
a look at it and he might email just the
levels figure out that he might be able
to spot that it was fake see the scars
yeah with a video you've got 30 frames a
second and the added challenge of
animation on top of it so you got a nail
at 30 times a second and you've got to
do the animation just perfectly mm-hmm
it's not gonna look right so it is
actually a big challenge there's only
been a few videos it's like actually one
it was somebody putting Nicolas Cage on
Rachel Adams face I've seen that one
yeah okay that's really the only one
where I've been like okay that's that's
as he very good the others a little
wonky and if it's like one even one
frame office they turn their head the
nose doesn't exactly line up like yeah
it's off yeah the blinking as another
big one doesn't blink enough the eyelids
don't know certainly because humans are
very good at reading faces that's why
the whole ego any value thing is like
the closest the closer you get to like
actual reality
the further away you get because it's
like it's uncanny it's something seems
off but here's the thing though those
are all just technical current
absolutely limitations hypothetically
let's say we get to a point where
machine learning has gotten so good that
it can just take any input of the video
and any input of a face and replace a
person within that video so flawlessly
even machine
analysis can't tell the difference
between what is real and versus fake
because that's just like with if you
throw any amount of progress it's like
as at a certain point it's gonna get
that good assuming that rate of progress
maintains mm-hmm
and these days all evidence is pointing
to that rate of progress is actually
accelerate it's gonna get there man like
so you're you're skeptical that it won't
even happen no okay so it it probably
will mmm it's I mean for one a lot of
people are just saying oh hey I will
figure it out which people say that it's
the magic box of AI like yeah I mean
it'll do it it's gonna get there
eventually like will it though I mean
you don't know I mean people have been
making wild predictions since the 60s
yeah ai
yeah Alan Turing himself predicted that
a machine would pass the Turing test by
the year 2000 back when nuclear power
was big they thought that we're gonna
have nuclear vacuum cleaners in the
1950s they thought when they had Rockets
that we were gonna be delivering rocket
mail right like when you you deliver
international mail by Rockets right so
there are predictions
maybe if SpaceX is successful that is
their exact mission yeah so the thing is
is like yet it's it looks very
convincing now there's still a lot of
limitations and will it get there yet to
be decided the own like I did a lot of
research on the AI think I haven't seen
any IAI yet be able to understand that
the geometry of something the depth like
and I feel like that's a big part of
this okay um it because when they went
like at the big tails like the moment
they turn their head the perspective is
all doesn't line up properly like that
the lighting has to match it as well you
got to put the highlights in the right
area because the skin has to reflect
that the right thing like understanding
I feel like understanding geometries a
big part of it
there's also other tales like you can
like the the blood actually punch it
goes to the face and you can see that
there's actually uh I don't know if it's
got a name but it will enhance the the
shades of blood in the face so you can
actually see blood pumping to the face
okay Wow
you can't see that in this AI this
neural network thing so that's a big
tell but that's not that but then maybe
that'll be there in the future they'll
figure that one out the eyelids I'll
figure that one out okay let's say that
happens okay what's the downside of
videos no longer being truthful what's
the what's the big sky is falling well
it just makes us that everything is
deniable i can go out and literally
punch someone in the face with full well
knowing that lots of cameras are around
recording that but then i can turn
around and literally be like no that
didn't happen and you have to prove that
it but it's like if you're only proof is
a video that is fey Keable mmm like wait
I mean I'm not saying that it's it's an
impossible challenge to to solve deep
fakes being such a common thing that
anyone can just do it 100% quality I'm
just saying it's like it is a challenge
and it is a problem yeah and I know some
people are some politicians are starting
to introduce Lola laws and bills into
place that would Australia's go on would
make it illegal to make a deep fake to
or at least it would make it illegal to
against somebody yeah put someone's
likeness against their will on to
someone else's thing
there's a girl in Australia who doesn't
know who's doing it but they keep making
a deep fake of her yet doing like porn
acts yeah and she doesn't know who's
doing it Wow and they just keep
uploading new and new things and she's
like so that she got a bill passed in
Australia and I'm not entirely convinced
that making it illegal is a bad idea
I think it it might actually I mean I
don't know cuz then you might just
reduce the widespread use of it so much
that it will happen it'll cause it's
still gonna happen you know like crime
still matters yeah but then it might
just be less so that when it does happen
you think these people are like
uploading it
currently under their real name well no
I'm just saying course it's not yeah but
they're already shady it's a bill it's
gonna do nothing I mean it I mean if the
repercussions are strong enough it might
make them think twice you know torrent
yeah because you'll still download
illegally like yeah you get a letter in
the mail saying hey wait
found you downloading this and it's like
okay so here's the other side of it okay
so it would erode our trust in video
absolutely yes just like we've already
done with photos so this is the thing
it's directly comparable to Photoshop
yeah in the 90s when Photoshop started
becoming a thing think about how scared
people were when Photoshop was around
like oh my goodness you can't trust
photos anymore now you can see when when
there's a you could you could Photoshop
the the president doing something that
he didn't do you could make him look
like he was performing sexual acts on
someone yeah this could cause World War
3 exactly the same does they say and we
did this ever really see that we never
really see what's happened is is
education the public has learned that
this is what Photoshop can do we've
adapted mm-hmm it will change things for
sure but it's not the end of the world
and this is the thing that I I'm not
suggesting it's like gonna be a huge
catastrophic problem oh no no but it all
the news above heart on the like how
someone could make a video of Donald
Trump saying he's just launched a
nuclear warhead and then it's gonna
actually start you know like big jumping
to like the craziest scenarios that like
video is like it I just don't see how
it's any different to photos and we
adapted to photos when you see a
billboard of a sexy girl like you know
that she's been airbrushed everybody
knows she's been airbrushed it's gonna
be the same with a video it's like but
it's like I just I feel that video is
kind of like the last bastion of reality
you know it's like yeah I mean we
obviously as visual effects artists we
are pushing the the border of that but
as entertainment versus politics if it's
in politics and then it's like you know
like I already don't trust what I I mean
I don't want really watch the news to be
honest but like someone else is telling
me something I'm like yeah
let me look into that you know and if
they like looking into it as an article
or a video or a speech or whatever like
maybe they'll just have to do speeches
and like disco ball lighting we're like
it's really hard to do you know the the
deep fake on it you know yeah I think
the other thing is like it's it's
exciting and is cool but it the news is
just like jumping over and I'm like
looking around I'm like guys why aren't
we talking about Photoshop like they
start the article like imagine a world
where like anyone could make you look
like you're doing something make you
look like you're performing sexual acts
on somebody else make you look like
you're being Vaughn so I'm like you mean
like Photoshop the thing we've had for
the last 20 years already yeah like it's
it'll change things for sure but it's
not and the other thing oh yeah okay see
I was gonna say the the consequence for
Kourt being caught making a fake video
like let's say a political party or
Russia wanted to make I don't know don't
from there's a video of don't Trump in
an elevator punching his wife right okay
let's say that happens right the
consequence of being caught making a
fake as in it goes up online but then
experts look at it and they break it
down and then they show a video that
it's been faked the consequence of that
looks terrible and for you yeah so you
have to nail it perfectly in order to
pull it off yeah and if it was in a
court case like if you had somebody like
trying to frame somebody for murder or
something then you're in really deep
trouble and it's a good point yeah like
so the consequence is huge so that's
stacked like that's preventing a lot of
people from trying it because a lot of
people aren't video experts and I were
getting the White House from doing it
know what they did they did that video
where it's like they sped up the footage
a little bit so I made it look like the
guy like karate-chopped a woman's arm
wasn't that yet I was immediately found
out it was like that was embarrassingly
bad it was it was it was yeah that was
it was like found out like the big day
of yeah I mean anybody could tell that
was that was so bad yeah
yeah well anyways I'm not I I don't want
to make it sound like I'm saying like
it's not a big deal like it's gonna
change things it's I was just surprised
like reading on Twitter like I you know
all these friends in the industry oh
yeah the thing I'm like Photoshop what's
the same same argument about how like oh
hey I is gonna take all our jobs it's
like it's not gonna take them as much as
just morph though yeah change over but
yeah yeah yeah it people are averse to
change anyways I mean it's gonna change
and adapt we'll figure it out yeah well
Andrew thank you so much yeah been a
pleasure talking with you yeah I really
hope you the rest of your stay here in
America is great and maybe we'll see you
again if you move back yeah I hope so
it's been fun yeah man
thanks for having me absolutely ain't
repress everyone from blender guru and
see you later and alright thank you so
much everyone for tuning in and watching
or listening this was a really fun
podcast I know Clint and I both really
enjoyed it so thanks again to Andrew
price for showing up and sitting with us
having some good discussions and if you
want to see more of this sort of thing
you can subscribe to the YouTube channel
corridor cast or you know what if you
just want to listen to it that's cool
too you can find them on pretty much any
of your favorite podcast platforms like
Spotify or iTunes whatever floats your
boat
so yeah thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time